hi Aaron you told me the other day that
you helped the small business evolve
their serverless app yes I did as their
business was growing they went through
several iterations of their application
architecture
couldn't they just have picked the
correct architecture right away
well at each stage of their growth they
picked the minimum technology to support
their business which I think was really
smart by iterating their architecture
they could learn from each stage and
they avoided spending a lot of money up
front can't wait to hear more
[Music]
all right Aaron what kind of a business
is it so it's a mobile hairdresser and
makeup business for special events like
weddings unlike a salon they perform the
service at the client's location
it sounds like a lot of businesses are
similar to that like plumbers
electricians and so on
well I would say the one major
difference is that the quality of makeup
in hair is much more subjective so the
client and the owner really need to have
a strong Mutual understanding of what
the service will be before the owner
agrees
ah so what was the first iteration of
their workflow it was very Bare Bones
they didn't have to write any code at
all what no code at all Aaron well if a
business can get away with writing no
code they should it'll mean lower
upfront costs and less maintenance down
the road yeah that makes sense so here
it is customers would call in to
schedule an appointment the business
owner would take the call and write down
the appointments in a Google sheet well
that's about as simple as it can get but
it seems like a lot of work for the
owner yes it was and it wasn't great for
customers either because they could only
make appointments when the business
owner was available on the phone got it
so how did they simplify the process uh
they built a website yeah for a while
they wanted to make a website that could
display their work link to social media
to follow the artist and answer FAQs
about the services still they didn't
want to write code for their own forms
or a back end to store responses yeah it
sounds like that would be a lot of extra
work did they find a better way well
they hosted the site in Firebase hosting
and put a link to a Google form in their
site that would send inputs directly to
their Google Sheets which they were
already using and this is important
they're designing this workflow around
what they are already good at so now
customers could request appointments
anytime even if the owner wasn't there
but the owner can still see everything
the way they're used to I like it still
not much code besides a static HTML
website but partial automation of the
workflow so are they still using that
setup well as the business started to
grow the owner was getting more client
requests than they could handle likewise
from working in the industry they
naturally started to meet other makeup
artists who would occasionally refer
clients when they were overbooked uh so
the owner didn't need to hire their own
employees artists could just work with
them temporarily as needed exactly and
the owner didn't want to share the
entire Google sheet with these other
artists just the customer information
that mattered for the specific jobs that
artist was working on they also needed a
way for the other artists to give status
updates like job complete or appointment
canceled so now they need to manage
these artists somehow to an extent but
this part of the business should run
itself as much as possible so that the
owner only really needs to intervene if
there was something like a last minute
cancellation
and how would the existing architecture
help them with this well the owner
needed a different approach for managing
the other artists they wanted Dynamic
updates to and from Google Sheets and
some form of auth to only let a signed
artists see their specific clients this
should be a separate experience from the
front end that customers see
sounds like a developer would be needed
for that how did the developer build on
their existing architecture well the
owner found a freelance developer who
could meet those requirements at the
right price now the owner didn't insist
on a particular Tech stack or cloud
provider because those types of
preferences were beyond their expertise
as an owner and they trusted the
developer to use what worked the
developer preferred containers as a
single deployment unit that could go
anywhere that's a good reason for using
containers yeah the developers container
met the needs it was easy and manageable
and they deployed the whole app in Cloud
run as a single container ah so they
just connected the cloudron app to
Google Sheets yes and you did a video
about that yes I did I'll share the link
in the description and after that they
were all done sheets work great for them
at a small scale but as the business
grew even further they felt the need for
a proper database
sheets is really designed for several
humans to use at the same time not for
several applications to be constantly
adding or looking up information a sheet
doesn't perform at scale compared to a
proper database wouldn't moving to a
database be a big jump
in this case the developer wanted to use
firestore which would be a smooth
transition it was easier for the
developer to set up and connect to forms
and Cloud run and since firestore is
serverless it's much easier to set up
and manage than a self-hosted database
firestore seems great for the
applications connected to it but what
did the owner think well remember the
owner liked sheets because they were
familiar with it they could do weekly
analytics to see Trends in their
business such as the frequency of new
appointments or what times of the year
we're getting the most heavily booked
and these aren't trivial issues either
they affect pricing and the demand for
artists so they're important for the
owner to stay on top of and it sounds
like they missed those requirements when
they replaced sheets with firestore
exactly but this situation is easy to
recover from these are pieces you can
take out and put back in So firestore
belongs in the place of a database yes
but you can export the data to Google
Sheets to make it easier to analyze and
navigate for the owner so with all the
things we've added and improved it all
started and ended with a Google sheet so
one thing that was really clear in this
case was the focus on the small business
even though it's a very simple
application every business should care
about keeping complexity to a minimum
and it sounds like you should be fine
with updating your architecture as
requirements change yes the idea that
you have this perfect image on day one
just isn't reality and it's actually
better to expect and be able to adapt to
change so owners need to make sure their
needs are being met regardless of the
tools and developers should have the
freedom to build things that meet those
requirements and I think one thing we
noticed is that serverless patterns are
great at supporting both owners and
developers because of their flexibility
well thank you for sharing their Journey
with us Aaron and thank you everyone for
watching you will find a link to the
other episode we talked about in the
show notes if you have any questions for
Aaron and me or suggestions for future
serverless topics please enter them in
the comments below we read every single
comment until next time
[Music]
foreign